thank you alejandro yes we are here with
jj who bounced back in style after
yesterday's uh loss uh jj tell us first
of all how does it feel to be back here
in st louis and play at the saint louis
tesla it's amazing i mean as always it's
great to be playing here and i was very
upset when the classics got canceled due
to covet but it's it's great to be back
and it's good to be
bouncing back after a tough loss
yesterday and it's great to have you
back and your typical brand of fire
chess on the board tell us a little bit
about yesterday's game but also about
today's game yeah yesterday things of
course didn't go too well i wanted to
surprise chris out of the opening a
little bit but i think he surprised me
back
with uh slightly unexpected move so i
mean i checked the h4 line actually but
i didn't look at the move knight f3 so i
wasn't very aware of those positions um
and after the opening i got a very
unpleasant position and of course it was
very tough to to get back and he didn't
give me any chances so but today i
wanted to play for two results uh a
winner
and if i lost but definitely draw was
not in my mind so i wanted to bounce
back and i'm lucky and i got the prep in
and it worked out well let's get right
into the game alejandro maybe you can
pull that one a little bit right your
board
and take us through the game gg yeah so
lately uh
he has been playing the semi sloth and i
played the same islam like my whole life
so i thought that this g3 system can be
annoying at times if black is not 100
sure of how to handle it
and uh he played one of the most
principled lines of course but it's it's
super sharp so it's exactly what i
wanted for today
knight d7 if yeah e4
it should be seven although it says
dubious it's actually one of the it's
the main line
and after knight d5 knight g5
yeah black can also play bishop e7 but i
think h6 is the the main move after
bishop e7 it goes on
with queen h5 g6 and so on
don't tell him all your secrets right
everybody's there listening and taking
notes yes so after age six
uh yeah the main move is knight e6 but
of course that has
a lot of lines where i think it's white
is still playing for something right
but it's too complicated and
it's like 30 moves of theory but i think
knight ge4 is underestimated because not
that many people play it first of all
white is down upon
and but i think there is a lot of
compensation of course
queen b6 natural black wants to probably
castle long at times and bishop e3 it
seems like at this point he was still
within his preparation uh he was playing
quite fast yeah i think he was surprised
with bishop e3 and uh there are only
like two three games in this position
and the idea is actually simply to
defend the pawn on d4
and i might want to go queen g4 queen h5
sometimes and the pawn on d4 has to be
defended i'm never afraid of knight
takes e3 because f takes just opens up
the f file
and that's going to be a big problem on
the f7 square yeah queen h5 is coming or
queen f3 is coming
and it's very very tricky
okay i in my opinion he played the most
logical
uh human moves and uh that is what i
mostly checked
and yeah here the move b3 i think was
important
where do you feel he's a big mistake
his big mistake
came at when after i played bishop f4 in
the game so i was still in my prep
until here and as far as i remember
after bishop f4 black has to play h5 for
some reason
and
i don't remember exactly
why what happens if i move the queen i
know computer screams queen takes h5
but
at the end it's a draw somehow but
i have no idea what happens if the queen
goes back
taking notes i'm never allowing my
students to play this variation
queen before rook ac1 and it seemed that
the pressure on both sides is very
difficult for black to deal with
i like that despite the fact that black
structure is very solid it's just a
piece activity it's not existent yeah
it's like alpha zero
and uh yeah i mean after queen before i
i was out of book but to me it's just
very unplayable to play with the black
pieces i don't know if i played it
perfectly but
it felt it felt good so oh i felt like a
very clean game yeah the move queen h5
the computer is not in love with but it
still gives you a huge advantage
and after this rook c7 it was basically
game over it's very difficult to defend
the black king and all the pieces at the
same time
yeah after bishop c8 i actually was
going to play htx g5 that i thought that
was the winning line after takes bishop
takes king d6 i thought rook fc won but
there's queen yuan check and i was super
annoyed when i saw this
because after rook takes rook h5
bishop f4 i think he can play e5 and i
have three pieces hanging at the same
time
and i have no idea like i can go rook d7
i guess but why am i going to be down in
exchange for
no reason actually maybe a full roller
yeah he takes the king right yeah
yeah i was not happy when i saw that so
i just played rook fc one immediately
and i think at that point
the game should be over yeah the game is
by all practical means over a very nice
bounce back here as abhimanya wasn't
able to defend his position
uh good job one out of two not bad at
all yeah i mean it's not bad clean game
jj congratulations and we're looking
forward to see you in the next rounds
yeah hopefully
we also